keeping it simple in the kitchen doesn't
mean you can't have amazing food that
not only looks incredible but tastes
fantastic too
my first recipe is so easy it removes
the stress from cooking and is a
pleasure to make chili beef lettuce
wraps
cooking should never be a chore the more
you cook the more confident you become
that way you actually start to enjoy it
and that's the key to good cooking have
a bit of fun along the way
this is minced beef and minced pork the
pork needs to sit in there otherwise the
beef's gonna dry out
it's really important to season the
mince before you cook it
pan nice and hot
touch of olive oil
mince in
breaking up like that
really helps to sort of separate it so
we can fry it off with a lot of color
with your spoon
just go through
and start breaking that up
the most important thing to remember is
mint is made up of cheap cuts brisket
belly
short rib so
it needs help
and frying off the mince for color it's
so important
if this pan wasn't hot your mince is
going to boil there's a horrible gray
color on there
and there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit
[Music]
tastes delicious it's seasoned
beautifully see how crispy it's going
take it
much further than you ever taken mints
before nice and crispy
smells incredible
draining it it's crucial it keeps the
mints nice and crispy and you get rid of
that
excess fat
that's lovely
now just wipe out the pan then wash it
low gas
now we're going to add texture to the
mince
finely chopped chili
ginger
garlic and spring onions
spring onions give this sort of mince a
really nice freshness
because it just gives that crunch
nice and thinly
now i'm gonna fry off the chilies the
ginger the garlic first
sesame seed oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in
fry that off nicely
the sesame seed oil just lifts up the
whole flavour
brown sugar that starts to really
caramelize the chili the garlic and the
ginger
mince in
now
my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness
you can see now why it's so important to
get that mince really crispy because
nothing's going soggy staying really
crispy
fresh lime
that makes the mince fragrant
and then
lime juice roll it
and squeeze that in there
[Music]
incredible i've got the salty
i've got the heat
i've got the sweetness now i've got the
acidicness as well and then finally my
spring onions in right at the last
minute so i've got crunch in there as
well smells
amazing
literally cook the mince now with sort
of 30 seconds
to go
gas off and take it out
looks incredible smells so inviting
[Music]
to go with the chili beef i'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce so
everyone can dress the crispy mince to
their own taste
dipping sauce little teaspoon
the brown sugar soy sauce
gives it a nice sort of dark rich color
sesame seed oil
a tablespoon and just top that up with a
tablespoon
of olive oil that stops the sesame seed
all becoming too rich
a teaspoon
of fish sauce and then a touch of chili
leave the seeds in again i want the heat
in that sauce
so impressive an amazing show off center
piece
lime juice in
in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up
just check the seasoning
that's lovely nice and rich
now the lettuce i'm going to use baby
gem because it's really nice and durable
and sort of quite strong
so you just sort of sit
these nice
trimmed lettuce leaves
around
now the exciting part serve take your
lettuce up
spoon in
your mince and then
a little touch of dressing
just a little drizzle
nice and that's the secret of having
good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself
food that looks and tastes a million
bucks doesn't have to be complex
this dish is as fun to cook as it is to
eat
[Music]
mushroom and leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers
one in front two behind
up and down
add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that's
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down through the center turn it
over
and again into quarters
see all that opening up and then just
rinse the top of that to get rid of any
potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add
all that leek
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now
the secret is to get rid of that water
inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic's got nice and crispy now we're
gonna add a touch of chicken stock in
there beautiful
lasagna sheets just gonna drop the
sheets in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken start to reduce down by half
and it's almost delayed the bottom of
the pan basically washed all that
wonderful flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the bowl and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early so you've got that
nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready
turn the sauce down
and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just going to turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now
pan for the bread little touch of olive
oil as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve i
want a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream
then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple that can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat i flavor packed lamb with fried
bread
whether i'm cooking high-end dishes or
rustic dishes trust me it all has to be
impressive so this lamb dish proves that
you don't have to spend a fortune to
create delicious food
first off put the pan on
this is a lamb steak and it's cut just
above the leg just here because you can
see that delicious bone running through
the center and that's full of marrow so
that just gives the lamb a nice added
sweet flavor
just take your knife cut through each
end this stops the
lamb steak from buckling so therefore it
cooks
evenly and colors beautifully salt
and pepper
lamb needs quite a lot of help with the
pepper so
be quite generous with the pepper
and just pat that down
the pan is just under smoke on the
outside now put the oil in get that pan
really nice and hot because this is a
cheap cut so
i'm depending on the color of the lamb
steak to really sort of impart a lot of
flavor
that's the noise you want to hear if you
can't hear that noise don't drop the
steak in
put a little bit of garlic in there not
chopped garlic just whole cloves the
garlic lightly crushed
don't even waste time peeling them in
tongs lift up
a bit of fat around the back
that's the top of the leg
tilt the pan and let all that fat render
rendering is a chef's term that means
melting the fat it works brilliantly
when you're cooking a rib eye as well
cut it over
that color there beautiful
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we've got that nice even sear
all over
as it's cooking just tilt the pan
and vase
and basting the lamb steak
just means you're sort of adding all
that nice scented
garlic olive oil back into the lamb
[Music]
now take the lamb out let the lamb rest
[Music]
now
for the perfect rustic crouton so this
bread's quite firm a couple of days old
just slice it straight down the center
dice it up
put it into a bowl
season it beautifully
[Music]
from there i'm gonna add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture
and just let that milk sort of absorb
into the bread while that's soaking i'm
gonna make the dressing go back to that
initial garlic that was in the pan
look at that beautiful into the pest and
water anchovies
anchovies go brilliantly well with lamb
i want that nice salty vinegary flavor
and a bit of kick some capers
the little baby cats very sweet
now
just pound that to a nice paste
that smells incredible
next some dijon mustard
a nice teaspoon and a half in a little
bit of red wine vinegar two tablespoons
and then our extra virgin olive oil
now
it's got that heat in there got a nice
roasted garlic a real hearty chunky
vinaigrette that sort of seeps into that
lamb
some fresh parsley
crunch up the parsley
delicious flavor parsley in
nice
now get your pan hot for the croutons
olive oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all that
excess milk out not too hard i don't
want them dry
and in
and then just fry them
and the milk inside these croutons
give it a nice spongy creamy delicious
flavor
that's the color i want
nice
now take them out and lightly drain them
a little bit kitchen roll onto the board
out
[Music]
to plate them just take this amazing
vinaigrette
and spread it
get those croutons listen to them
like little boulders hitting the play
the lamb
let's sit that on
next one
on
the rest of the croutons
on
now use all those little bits
and my chef in paris would kill me right
now if you saw me using those because
they're the ugly scraps that customers
should never see but but they're the
best bits
croutons on
and then just
drop that sauce
on all those little bits
of the lamb
and there that is a perfect way
of taking a cheap cut
into the premier league of dishes
you